it's the second most populated country
on earth
as the seventh biggest economy
has one of the ten biggest military
budgets in the world
and is a nuclear power however
india is a stranger in political terms
if i were to ask you who's the prime
minister of india could you tell me
now i am aware that many of you will
actually know this especially if you're
watching this video
from india but if you don't know who the
prime minister of india is don't worry
because
well that happens a lot
on the 26th of may 2014 after an
absolute majority which had not been
seen in 30 years
narendra modi became the prime minister
of india modi's mission
well it was clear boost growth
investment and create millions of jobs
in conclusion turn india into a
superpower capable of competing with
china on an economic
political and military
india dear level viewers is something of
an eternal promise
it's always that country that seems to
be the next one that's going to take off
but it never really does we can see that
this is definitely the case if we take a
look at india's gdp
and compare it to that of china
[Music]
they've seen quite different economic
development in the last few decades so
with modi's victory expectations are
once again high and
india has again become the talk of the
town modi is repeating over and over
again that the 21st century is going to
be
india's century but before we get into
all of that let's take a look at modi
himself
[Music]
who is narendra modi vegetarian single
and a yoga enthusiast modi escapes the
traditional politician profile
he comes from a family of limited means
and when he was a child used to help his
father sell tea
in a train station this has helped him
earn the sympathy of many poor people
in the country they see him as an
example of a rags to rich's story and
shows that rags to riches in india can
sometimes work
his political ideology has always been
very attached to hinduism and he has not
always taken a moderate approach
in fact before getting involved with the
bjp party he was involved with the rss
party
the rss party is an extreme right party
that had mahatma gandhi's assassin as
one of its members
for 13 years between 2001 and 2014 modi
was the regional prime minister in the
state of gujarat gujarat with its 65
million inhabitants has become under
modi's leadership
india's greatest economic driver with an
annual growth rate of
[Music]
alongside these impressive figures
social welfare has also greatly improved
almost every home has access to plumbing
electricity
and preschool education while the
general election in india was taking
place modi promised to replicate what
had done
in his state in the rest of india
furthermore he promised to do this
in just 10 years which is only two
political terms
this is because for modi the year 2022
is a landmark year
it's the 75th anniversary of india's
independence
the country will also surpass china as
the world's most populous country
reaching a population of 1.6 billion
people modi says that by the year 2022
it's going to be clear that the 21st
century
is india's century
this is certainly not going to be easy
especially in a country where the
population is growing
by 28 people every minute
[Music]
india's major problems
now india has many problems but three do
stand out as particularly important
the first is that india is a
bureaucrat's paradise
in fact if bureaucracy was the key to
prosperity india would probably be the
most prosperous country
in the world unfortunately though
bureaucracy instead of encouraging
business
actually prevents it john kerry has
blamed the indian bureaucracy for
putting roadblocks
in the growth of indian economy
according to the doing business report
from the world bank which estimates how
easy it is to do business
india occupies the 130th position
each step of the way to establishing a
business in india takes a ton of
documents
and then the taxes are not only high not
that anyone really pays them but they
are also a
nightmare to sort out for example there
are not only different taxes in each
individual state but there are sometimes
different taxes for each individual
product or different models of the same
product
this is something that commonly happens
with vehicles and it is a
real nightmare for anyone to work out
of further absenteeism among public
workers has reached such a critical
state
that some hospitals have been forced to
close temporarily because of a lack of
staff the second big problem is that
regulations in the marketplace
make it so complicated that the market
is barely able to function
on the borders between different states
you'll find trucks that are just queuing
to cross the border not a few people say
that it's actually easier to import
something from abroad than it is to get
something from another state
further there is the terrible state of
the country's infrastructure as well
[Music]
as a consequence of this it is estimated
that half of the country's harvest goes
to waste
every year because of these delays and
the third big problem is that corruption
is a big
issue in indian society as a quick
example of this it is estimated that 50
of all money that the government gives
for welfare either ends up in the hands
of corrupt politicians or middlemen and
so this
is the country that modi is having to
deal with
[Music]
the new government's policies
the revolution that some have suggested
has not yet taken place however the
truth is is that the government
has achieved some notable advances for
example we could highlight the following
in order to reduce bureaucracy the
government has created a committee with
the purpose of determining which rules
and regulations are obsolete and should
be eliminated
so far they've done away with more than
1700 of these rules modi has also
eliminated many restrictions on foreign
investment
he has passed the first bankruptcy law
and has set up a powerful plan to make
india a destination for businesses
he has also set forth an ambitious plan
for better financial inclusion
this plan has a pretty unpronounceable
name so i'm just gonna show it on the
screen now
and this plan has basically allowed for
people to have a bank account for the
first time the number of people who've
taken this up is about 200 million and
this basically means that that welfare
money that is coming from the government
doesn't have to go
through any middlemen further the
government has also put forth a plan to
simplify the very complicated tax system
having a flat
sales tax at the national level
modi has also announced that they're
going to be spending a lot of money on
infrastructure with
130 billion dollars being spent on rail
by 2020. so again this year the plan is
to really connect a lot of these small
towns and cities to the
main national highway and the target of
the government is to construct 10 000
kilometers of road
every year but these aside modi's most
risky move so far
happened in november of 2016.
india's cash crisis in order to fight
corruption
india suddenly made the country's 500
and 1 000 rupee notes illegal these
represented 85 percent of
all of the hard cash in india a country
that is really a cash-based economy the
goal was to find
dirty money and punish it when the
owners came into the bank to switch out
their 500 and a thousand notes for ones
in the new design
however the plan was an utter disaster
the government didn't have enough cash
to replace the money that people wanted
to exchange
further the country's atms weren't
working properly because the new
currency was a different shape to the
old currency and the atms hadn't been
adjusted
i don't know what to do people here have
no money to buy my products so i can't
buy stock from the market either
it's the end of my business this was a
botched operation that left the country
moneyless and caused significant damage
to the economy
sales fell in november by more than 30
percent many businesses simply weren't
able to pay their workers and many
business transactions had to be
cancelled
some studies estimate that the total
damage was two points of india's gdp
this would mean that the banknote switch
cost india 50 billion dollars and
unfortunately the poorest in the country
were the hardest hit
then the government tried to say that it
was all part of some big plan to
encourage people to use more electronic
money
ah politicians
foreign policy agenda now this is the
field where the prime minister has
really excelled
in his first year alone he visited 19
countries
despite the fact that he's only been in
power for a short amount of time he has
achieved some notable advances
the pakistan treaty has improved
india-pakistani relations and a
relationship with china has started
dealing with some economic
and commercial issues at a joint press
conference
president xi jinping announced 20
billion us dollars worth of investment
in india's infrastructure in five years
however without any doubt the greatest
strength of modi's political agenda has
been his approach to the united states
the chemistry between obama and modi has
been quite significant
and their encounters have been frequent
and friendly they have both even
published an article together in the
washington post
so what we really need to ask now is
will modi achieve his goals
there are certainly a great deal of
challenges that he is going to have to
overcome
for example it's been made clear to the
prime minister just how tricky it is to
put limits on bureaucracy further modi
has avoided many essential reforms such
as ending
india's labor regulation which has meant
that four out of every five
jobs in the country are on the grey
market modi claims to be an
admirer of lee kuan yew singapore's
ex-prime minister
but modi doesn't seem to have the same
drive or determination to transform
india's model so this
is just our opinion here at
visualpolitik and we would love to know
what you think do you think that the
21st century is going to be india's
century do you think that modi is going
to achieve all that he has set out to
achieve
do let us know in the comments below
we'd love to hear from you also please
do give this video a thumbs up if you
enjoyed it and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos every monday and
thursday
and as always i'll see you next time
the